something we got to talk about
so I know that there are some men in my comments
that are truly disgusting and infuriating right
like I'm talking the
abortion is murder keep your legs shut crowd
and I'm here to remind you
that about 80% of the country supports abortion access
I'm talking Republicans and Democrats alike
so it's not always the best use of your time to be arguing
and getting in these common debates
as much as I love the engagement right
I selfishly love that
but it's not the best use of your activist energy to be engaging with them
because they represent a really small
extremist portion of the country
we don't need their votes
you don't need to win them over
this is Lily she's cwazy
focus on sharing accurate information
focus on talking to people who you think might not be registered
focus on people who you think wanna learn about this issue
remember in every state where abortion has been on the ballot
where voters have had a direct chance to vote on the issue
even in red states abortion access has succeeded
it is what voters want
but if you wanna debate with Chad in my comments for two hours
that's fine too